je viens d'avoir une très bonne nouvelle
en fait je vais avoir de l'argent par un
prince nigérian qui lui même vient
d'hériter et je vais l'aider à
transférer l'argent dans un autre compte
en échange de quoi il va me donner une
petite fortune
du moins c'est ce qu'ils disent mais je
le crois
[Musique]
l'escroquerie dite des princes nigérian
n'est absolument pas neuve
on peut remonter jusqu'au xviiie siècle
c'est très simple il ya une personne qui
se présente qui vous écrit la plupart du
temps et qui dirige une grande somme
d'argent faut que la transfert et j'ai
besoin d'être donc vous l'aidez en
échange de quoi
ben ils voulaient qu'une petite somme
d'argent l'escroquerie arrive au moment
où cette personne là vous demande
d'avancer les fonds pour l'aider à
sortir l'argent question bien sûr vous
ne revoyiez jamais cet argent est au 19e
siècle
c'est vidocq qui est un délinquant qui
est devenu éventuellement un policier
qui va écrire un livre dans lequel il va
expliquer l'escroquerie c'est ce qu'on
appelle les lettres de jérusalem ça
explose au 20e siècle et on en retrouve
beaucoup et ça vient principalement du
nigeria donc l'escroquerie des princes
nigérian consiste à voir une lettre un
peu comme celle ci dans laquelle on vous
explique qu'on a besoin de vos services
pour faire passer de l'argent d'un
compte à un autre par voie diplomatique
il va en avoir énormément ça fonctionne
très bien et avec internet ça explose
véritablement les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne vont se rendre compte
que c'est un problème on va donc intenté
des poursuites vers le nigéria pour dire
que cette pratique là elle n'est plus
acceptable
c'est ce qu'on va appeler le code 4 1
oeuf du nom de l'article qui sanctionne
ces pratiques au nigeria mais ça va pas
les empêcher de continuer si vous ouvrez
votre boîte courriel n'est pas rare
qu'on trouve des gens qui se présentent
comme étant des princes qui ont de
l'argent et ont besoin de vous pour
faire passer cet argent là d'un conte
vers un autre
mais moi c'est vrai j'y crois
ou pas